julius pope julius the first no relation
to orange julius the drink shop
chose december 25th to be christmas it
is commonly believed
that the church chose this date in an
effort to adopt and absorb the tradition
of the pagan
santornalia festival santana it sounds
like something sergio ciccone would
dance to
yeah here's the thing i i mean what are
the chances now i believe in god
i really do you do now you believe in
god you have a baby almost died
now you believe in god i've had multiple
life and death experiences
i took an old clown up in a old sausage
out of fridge i had my
heart rate going down to 20. i you know
they had to give me an adrenaline shot
with you if there's no in between either
heart rate's too low or too high yeah i
went you can't figure it out i [ __ ]
got shot with a gun i've been
electrocuted by lightning
yeah uh you gotta like oh you think an
electric bike struck by lightning
i've been shot with a gun now i got
coveted i was never really in danger of
dying though from coven but
if they if i didn't go to the hospital
my sodium levels that could have got
weird you could have gone weird but you
couldn't work but but it didn't happen
but they are kind of brushes with with
that of course they are
and um yeah i mean i'm not i don't know
if this is true
but there's definitely something bigger
sure
and it may be an [ __ ] too i mean if
you look at the way animals eat each
other and the way things are and that
there's fumes in the world
he may be an [ __ ] could be god could
be an [ __ ] could it be because why
make fumes
they can't fumes are unnecessary it
can't be god and hyenas
it's one of the other it's one of the
[ __ ] other but my question to you is
jesus christ what are the chances he
just
was not mentally ill yeah
because i think i thought i was jesus
for about a week in college jesus there
is a many people and i ride the line
yeah you ride the line because the dead
sea scrolls which you know became
popular when they got found
i don't know 30 40 years ago um they
kind of say that
jesus christ jesus who who the bible
goes who
who counsel of niceas picked as the
jesus that we know the guy
who's painted on my back um was tattooed
on my back
that guy that guy you and bobby de niro
in cape fear yeah okay
so that guy he was one of there were
upwards of 12 to 15 people
in that hundred year time saying they
were the messiah so
council of nicio just picked one just
picked once no doubt about it there was
a man
well named jesus doing what he was doing
that his name was
jesus i love the way you pronounce it
jesus jesus you hear the way he's saying
it
jesus jesus jesus because but but
there's
a lot of puerto ricans they've jesus too
there was a many people yeah cuz make no
mistake
make no mistake i just got a house on
staten island and there's gonna be a lot
of weddings in my backyard
oh yeah that's yeah it's again i got a
nice low interest rate shout out to
scumbag mortgage
please don't don't don't don't give me a
2.5 you don't know
chrissy no you've already gotten legal
things no no but no but i'm saying
they're good i'm saying the 2.5 million
she called him a scumbag
no no but i mean i i don't mean scuba i
mean i i shouldn't have said scumbag i
meant uh
sleazy i mean i i whatever i cuz you
come out with a 2.5 interest rate
something's illegal but i'm listening
yeah and i'm [ __ ] in for the low rate
cause it's got the ten-year-old mortgage
if i could put your if i could make an
analogy for your mouth it would be the
wild west
yes you're billy the kid yeah you're
you're you're
your mouth is this bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang what it is yosemite
sam yeah it's almost like you got
three mouths yeah like neil brennan's
three mics it's three mics i got three
guys over here
you got trouble over here and you got
drama over here
it's one of the three bikes i got three
mouths you should do a special where
here you go okay now i'm gonna lie
yeah yeah yeah now i'm gonna tell the
story i'm gonna tell straight it's not
true
okay now here i'm gonna tell you about
my anxiety that's true
i'm twitching i'm twitching night
terrorist night terrors yeah and now i'm
gonna go over here where i'm [ __ ] um
it's a [ __ ] spin the wheel baby i'm
back together with my baby's mama yeah
back to
my baby mom with more mouths to feed
what can you do i got duped in to buy a
house on staten island it's
christy three mikes is there a chance he
wasn't mentally ill i mean
i could i thought i was jesus christ for
a little while you thought you were
jesus christ
that's an issue did you really genuinely
think does your fever get that high that
you started to hallucinate for real no
when i was in college though i went
i i think i had a little moment where i
had like a little megalomania
right and i thought like oh am i jesus
you know
right yeah right stresses things like
that you know yeah
also do you think he could be an alien
could jesus be an alien
why the hell not cuz i mean the [ __ ]
the israelis said that the aliens are
real and they have a contract with them
maybe the contract started
around now it's very possible because
yeah one guy always comes out and says
that [ __ ]
i mean there's no [ __ ] aliens here i
mean if they were here
no we're in a contract with them that's
what the israeli has defensively
what contract they sat down with their
lawyers yes with their [ __ ] alien
lawyers
that's what they say cuz i mean if
people say all types of things that's
the problem with the internet
that's why i got blocked by dave rubin
because at one point
you know at one point in uh november he
goes
can we at least admit that the
pandemic's over and i just
lost it i also made it with my brother
and we cried we cried we cried it's been
a lot of atoning going on that's what it
is atonement
because i'm on mali right now yeah
that's what it is i'm on my own
no i'm on nature's molly right yeah
yanni is on drugs right now i have no
mistake
i will i want to touch all you guys yeah
do you want some cbd gummies we got five
cbd
shut up five cbd everything's live
everything's alive these cameras are
live i want to touch them
i'll get an erection touching these
cameras yeah because remember
we're a [ __ ] cosmic [ __ ] pinball
machine i got therapy in one minute yeah
you got a therapy woman because just do
we pause it and just finish it later
because we're having so much
fun dude or do you got babies to pick up
and are there jews on the windows
there's jews on the windows
yeah i mean i'll see how long i could
stay i got it even though i put an offer
in a house i'm taking a look at another
house
on staten island i actually got five
minutes
what are you doing for christmas i'm
[ __ ] saluting kamala harris
it's what it is that's what i'm doing
too yeah i mean i can't see my [ __ ]
mud on christmas i'm not why not
why not well no because i don't think
we're doing small endure i think we're
gonna do [ __ ] and we're gonna do
thanksgiving
and i don't actually know i think i am
doing we are going to do christmas
because i mean yeah the [ __ ] truth is
ridgewood is just doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the virus
i know they don't and the thing is you
it seems like you just can't get it
i don't know i'm still i'm still really
i'm proceeding with caution but i know
i do not know i mean if there was a few
times where it was like
how didn't you get it yeah i don't know
it's almost like pimp doesn't get it
either no but pimp is
always strapped yeah i mean she's
pimping strapped
pimp strap yeah like i said pimp walks
around looking like he's about to paint
the ceiling
yeah yeah you yeah you you raw daddy i
don't know yeah i don't even when we
were on election night you were
screaming at them for them to take their
masks off and you invited another person
in here
yeah so my wife is going what is chrissy
doing and i'm going
the kid doesn't feel unless there's
danger in the air it's what it is